now that we know a little bit about
vectors and scalars let's try to apply
what we know about them for some pretty
common problems you'd once see in a
physics class but they're also common
problems you'd see in everyday life
because you're trying to figure out how
far you've gone or how fast you're going
or how long it might take you to get
someplace so first I have if Shantanu
was able to travel five kilometers north
in one hour in his car what was his
average velocity so one let's just
review a little bit about what we know
about vectors and scalars so they're
giving us that he was able to travel
five kilometers to the north so they
gave us a magnitude that's the five
kilometers that's the size of how far he
moved and they also give a direction so
he moved a distance of five kilometers
distance is the scalar but if you give
the direction to you get the
displacement so this right here is a
vector quantity he was displaced five
kilometers to the north and he did it in
one hour in his car what was his average
velocity so velocity and there's many
ways that you might see it defined but
velocity once again is a vector quantity
and the way that we differentiate
between vector and scalar quantities is
we put little arrows on top of vector
quantities normally they are bolded if
you can have a typeface and they have an
arrow on top of it but this tells you
that not only do I care about the value
of this thing I care about or I care
about the size of this thing I also care
about its direction that's what the
arrow the hour isn't necessary erection
just tells you that it is a vector
quantity so the velocity of something is
its change in its change in position
including the direction of its change in
position so you could say it's
displacement its displacement and the
letter for displacement is s and that is
a vector quantity so that is
displacement and you might be wondering
why didn't why don't they use D for
displacement that seems like a much more
natural first letter and my best sense
of that is once you start doing calculus
you start using D for something very
different you use it for the derivative
operator and that's so that the DS don't
get confused
and that's why we use s for displacement
if someone has a better explanation of
that feel free to feel free to to
comment on this video and then I'll add
another video explaining that better
explanation so velocity is your
displacement over time is your
displacement over time if I wanted to
write an analogous thing for the scalar
quantities I could write that speed I
could write and I'll write out the word
so we don't get confused with
displacement or maybe I will write rate
rate is another way that sometimes
people write speed so this is the vector
version if you care about direction if
you don't care about direction you would
have your rate so this is rate or speed
is equal to the distance that you travel
the distance that you travel over over
some time so these two you could call
them formulas or you can call them
definitions although I would think that
they're pretty intuitive for you how
fast something is going you say how far
did it go over some period of time these
are essentially saying the same thing
this is when you care about direction so
you're dealing with vector quantities
this is where you're not so
conscientious about direction and so you
use distance which is scalar and use
rate or speed which is scalar here use
the displacement and you use velocity
now with that out of the way let's
figure out what his average velocity was
and this keyword average is interesting
because it's possible that his velocity
was changing over that whole time period
but for the sake of simplicity we're
going to assume that it was kind of a
constant velocity or what we are
calculating is going to be his average
velocity but don't worry about it you
can just assume that it wasn't changing
over that time period so his velocity
his velocity is his displacement was
five kilometers to the north so his
displacement the displacement was five
kilometers
five kilometers all right just a big
capital well let me just write it out
five kilometers north over his the
amount of time it took him over the
amount of time and let me make it clear
this is change in time change in time
sometimes this is also change in time
sometimes you'll just see a t written
there
sometimes you'll see someone actually
put this little triangle the character
Delta in front of it which explicitly
means change in it looks like very fancy
mathematics when you see that but a
triangle in front of thing something
literally means change in change in so
this is change in time so it goes five
kilometers north and it took him one
hour so the change in time was 1 hour so
let me write that over here so over 1
hour so this is equal to if you just
look at the if you just look at the
numerical part of it it is 5 over 1 let
me just write out 5 over 1 kilometers
and you can treat the units the same way
you would treat the quantities in a
fraction 5 over 1 kilometers
Coulomb eaters per hour kilometers per
hour and then to the north to the north
or you could say this is the same thing
as 5 kilometers per hour north so this
is 5 kilometers per hour per hour to the
north to the north to the north so
that's his that's his average velocity 5
kilometers per hour now you have to be
careful you have to say to the north if
you want velocity if someone just said 5
kilometers per hour they're giving you a
speed or rate or a scalar quantity you
have to give the direction for it to be
a vector quantity you could do the same
thing if someone just said what does
your average is what was his average
speed over that time you could have said
well his average speed or his rate would
be the distance he travels the distance
we don't care about the direction now
it's five kilometers and he does it in
one hour his change in time is one one
hour so this is the same thing as five
five kilometres per hour so once again
we're only giving the magnitude here
this is a scalar quantity if you want
the vector you get you have to do the
north as well now you might be saying
hey you know in the previous video we
talked about things in terms of meters
per second here I gave you kilometres or
kilometers depending on how you want to
pronounce it km/h what if someone wanted
in m/s or what if I just wanted to
understand how many how many meters he
travels in a second and there just
becomes a unit conversion problem and I
I figure it doesn't hurt to to work on
that right now so if we wanted to do
this to m/s how would we do it well the
first step is to think about how many
meters we are traveling in an hour
so let's take that five kilometers per
hour and we want to we want to convert
it to we want to convert it to meters so
I put meters in the numerator and I put
kilometers in the denominator and the
reason why I do that is because the
kilometers are going to cancel out with
the kilometers and how many meters are
there per kilometer well there's 1000
meters for every one kilometer 1000
meters for every one kilometer and I set
this up right here so that the
kilometers cancel out so these two
characters cancel out and if you
multiply you get five five and then the
only unit you have in the five I should
say five thousand so you have five times
a thousand so this is let me write this
five times I'll doing the same color
five times 1000 so I just multiplied the
numbers when you multiply something you
can switch around the order
multiplication is commutative I always
have trouble pronouncing that an
associative and then in the unit's in
the numerator you have meters and in the
denominator you have hours meters per
hour and so this is this is equal to
this is equal to five thousand five
thousand meters per hour and you might
say hey Sal you know I could have you
know I know that five kilometers is the
same thing as five thousand meters I
could do that in my head and you
probably could but this cancelling out
de mint or what's often called
dimensional analysis right here can get
useful once you start doing really
really complicated things with less
intuitive units than something like this
but this should you should always do an
intuitive gut check right here you know
that if you do five kilometers in an
hour that's a ton of meters right so it
should get you should get a larger
number if you're talking about meters
per hour and now when we want to go to
second
let's do an intuitive gut check if
something is traveling a certain amount
in an hour it should travel a much
smaller amount in a second or you know
136 hundredths of an hour because that's
how many seconds there are in an hour
so that's your gut check we should get a
smaller number than this when we want to
say m/s but let's actually do it with
the dimensional analysis so we want to
cancel out the hours and we want to left
be left with seconds in the denominator
so the best way to cancel this hours in
the denominators by having hours in the
new-new in the denominator in the
numerator so you have hours per hours
per seconds so how many hours are there
per second or another way to think about
it one hour think about the larger unit
one hour is how many seconds well you
have 60 60 seconds per minute times 60
minutes per second the minutes cancel
sorry times 60 minutes per hour I should
say times 60 minutes per hour the
minutes cancel out 60 times 60 is 3,600
seconds per hour 3,600 seconds per hour
or if you flip it if you so you could
say this is 3600 seconds for every one
hour or if you flip them you would get
one over 3,600 hours or hour per second
or hours per second depending how you
want to do it so one hour is the same
thing as 3,600 3,600 seconds and so now
this hour cancels out with that hour and
then you multiply or appropriately
divide the numbers right here and you
get this is equal to 5,000 over 3,600
over 3,600 meters meters per all you
have left in the denominator here is
second meters per second and if we
divide both the numerator and the
denominator by well we could I could do
this by hand but just because this video
is already getting a little bit long let
me get my trusty calculator out
if I get my trusty calculator out just
for the sake of time five thousand
divided by 3,600
which would be really the same thing as
50 divided by 36 that is 1.3 I'll just
round it over here 1.3 9 so one point
this is equal to 1.3 9 meters per second
1.3 9 meters let me meet what 1.3 9
meters per meters per second so Shantanu
was travelling quite slow in his car
well we knew that just by looking at
this 5 kilometers per hour that's pretty
much just letting the car roll roll
pretty pretty slowly